vidyo nallet la raison ni l'algo le
climat n'attend pas disons qu'il ya des
arguments assez fort mais qui a quand
même au moins un problème c'est que
c'est un peu une attitude je dirais
d'indépendantistes catalan parce que
certes 60 % des parisiens n'ont pas de
voiture mais la circulation automobile
privé dans paris elle est absolument
indispensable à un très grand nombre de
banlieusards et donc interdire la
voiture ce serait très provoqué de très
grandes difficultés pour cela alors sauf
si on mettait en place mais personne ne
parle de ça des vrais plans de création
de vastes parkings tout autour de l'est
de la grande métropole pour que les
banlieusards puissent s'approcher de la
capitale est immédiatement enclenché sur
un moyen de transport commode mais tel
que c'est annoncé si c'est un coup du
même genre que les voies sur berge juste
pour faire plaisir à des parisiens
contre les autres franchement oui je
trouve ça un peu j'aime pas l'expression
qu'attali bande d'enfants les catalyst
on va dire